in case you missed the spectacular
sunset just wanted to share at least one
of the photos that was coming in look at
this this was after just the sun was
setting the color was starting to set
into the sky this was sent to me by
paula francis you might know that name
paula francis former evening anchor for
eight news now for many many many years
the gorgeous colors that started to take
shape in our skies yesterday evening
were phenomenal and then the pinks
turned into vivid reds and oranges so
beautiful we love clouds at sunrise and
sunset here in the desert it just makes
for spectacular displays of color i'll
show you more as we get through the
morning hours all right so we're going
to still see a few of those clouds
around this morning mid 40s back by 9
a.m we'll be up to about 50 degrees as
the clouds are shifting out sunshine
takes over and we'll look for a little
bit of a warmer day mid 50s by the
afternoon hours yesterday only 49 but i
think with more sunshine to work with
we'll see a little bit warmer day we're
on a warming trend with high pressure
rebuilding over the desert this week
let's jump on the road say good morning
to nate tannenbaum check the drive good
morning sharon good morning paula
francis
that is awesome thanks paula
freeways are in excellent shape as
you're getting going here on your
tuesday morning you might see a couple
of specks of